matthieu delormeau troisième saison dans
tpm paix savait qu'on vous aime votre
première phrase dans tpm pont lasveyras
tout à l'heure vous verrez pourquoi
parce qu'elle est un petit peu
particulière j'ai pu mais c'est très
intelligent
comment vous avez été recruté vous vous
m'avez appelé vous m'avez dit j'ai
besoin de gens célèbres maintenant
autour de la table la vérité non j'avais
été remerciés d'un commun accord avec
nrj12 par là avec eux mêmes j'ai été
dégagée d'nrj12 et vous m'avez appelé on
m'avait dit ça serait bien qu'on se
rencontre pour voir peut-être l'année
prochaine faire quelque chose ensemble
partout pour moi j'en ai à votre bureau
à une heure précise qui était 10 heures
je suis passé à 11h45
j'ai attendu une heure quarante-cinq ans
bah quand même combat et quand je suis
monté ben on s'est rencontré et vous
fait vous m'avez dit toi tu es
intelligent tu seras tu seras le
monsieur médias là on va ta bille et
bien cravate même un hammam un soutien
très bien très bien
mais monsieur sur cette petite anecdote
cocasse vous m'aviez dit c'est quoi ton
tarifs
alors j'ai dit je veux tu en es tu m'as
dit c'est bon le tarif c'est bon et
c'est un contrat de un an
deux semaines après j'arrive chez h2o
c'est un contrat de trois mois tarik
était à moitié
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas moi qui les côtoient
dénonce-t-il
alors merci de lui comment vous l'avez
été recrutés vont m'appeler pendant les
vacances de noël 2016 à 10 m et bull est
ce que tu veux participer à l'émission
en tant qu'expert médias on a envie de
légitimer un peu le programme sur la
partie civile c'est vraiment planté ses
on était à côté ce qu'on dit quand on
veut séduire ça on était sur l'a13 ont
appris la table et je me suis dis
franchement c'est une belle opportunité
c'est quitte ou double soit je me plante
totalement ce qui est arrivé on le début
janvier sharif et le 5 janvier et les
émissions précédentes je les ai regardés
avec les plus grands des sunnites a
séduite et je tremblais tous mes membres
n'ont jamais inquiété de l' extrêmement
peur et dès que je suis arrivé à lakanal
factory tout mon stress est des partis
je m'installe à la salle maquillage et
anorak me fais mes jeunes hommes qui
êtes vous je suis à l'expert média du
jour
ah ouais je le sais bien on n'a pas de
beau gosse dont l'équipe a après le fait
et on va m'a fait une petite bise sur la
joue
et puis j'ai trouvé l'amour elle nous
racontera sa la vue et puis après du fil
en aiguille semaine après semaine john d
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'il y a la prétention du gatt
donc du banc que d'être beau gosse de
l'émission
non je n'ai rien dire ça mais année
d'enora l'époque il était comme ça
derrière moi et très gentils en fait
elle dit ça tout le monde et lannion lui
pose la question
voilà dix à laval ses amis très à l'aise
et j'ai fait des émissions et la 11e
j'ai eu mon premier cachet laquelle
humanitaires de la crise et une fois
toujours bien fait ce qu'il y a déplié
une fois aujourd'hui c'est pas mal pour
que vous m'attaquez je paye rugby sur la
gauche mais est ce que vous rappelez de
votre première phrase oh là là non ce
que pensait qu'elle était intéressant je
ne pense pas oui bah et ben voila si mme
kenny de médias plus justement c'est
tout l'intérêt de mettre l'accent sur
les chefs
dès lors la cuisine revenu à casser les
schémas habituels de cette émission avec
sauf que c'est chez moi d'émotion
également pour eux et contrairement à ce
qu'on peut penser aux émissions ne fait
pas moins d'audience que l'année
dernière sont en location sans promotion
de 0,7 point joue sous la vue demeure y
avait des navets le là quelque chose
[Applaudissements]